el siglo 18 en europa a menudo se conoce
como la era de la ilustración habíamos
salido del renacimiento habíamos
redescubierto la ciencia y la razón y en
el siglo 18 vimos ocurrir eso con un
progreso de la sociedad aún mayor cuando
salimos del siglo y entramos al siglo 19
comenzó la revolución industrial y la
gente atestigua la marcha constante de
la razón humana del progreso humano y
debido a esto mucha gente decía hey la
humanidad continuará mejorando mejorará
para siempre hasta el punto en que la
pobreza desaparecerá nos convertiremos
en esta civilización utópica perfecta
sin guerras y sin conflictos de ningún
tipo y había algo que decir al respecto
hubieron mejoras significativas
de hecho hubieron mejoras aún más
dramáticas una vez que comenzó la
revolución industrial pero a finales del
siglo 18 no todos eran optimistas y una
de las personas no tan optimistas más
famosas fue thomas malthus justo aquí y
lo citaré directamente esto es de su
ensayo sobre el principio de población
de la población es tan superior al poder
que tiene la tierra para producir el
sustento del hombre que la muerte
prematura de una forma u otra debe
llegar a la raza humana los vicios de la
humanidad son agentes activos y capaces
de despoblación son los precursores del
gran ejército de destrucción y a menudo
terminan ellos mismos este terrible
trabajo pero si fracasan en esta guerra
de exterminio las enfermedades las
epidemias la peste y la plaga son
quienes avanzan en terrible formación
arrasando con miles y decenas de miles
si el éxito aún es incompleto la
inevitable hambruna gigantesca acecha en
la retaguardia y de un poderoso golpe
nivela la población con el alimento del
mundo así que no es tan alentador a esta
pequeña cita pero esta era su sensación
general vivió en una época en que la
gente era muy optimista de que el
progreso la marcha del progreso
continuaría para siempre hasta llegar a
una civilización utópica pero desde su
punto de vista thomas malthus pensó que
si las personas pudieran reproducirse y
aumentar la población lo harían
que no había forma de detenerlos desde
la forma en que lo vio permítanme
dibujar ese eje digamos que esa es la
población y este eje de aquí es el
tiempo entonces según su pensamiento y
todo lo que había visto en realidad
hasta ese momento respaldaría esto que
si las personas tuvieran suficiente
comida y tiempo se reproducirían y
reproducirían en cantidades que
aumentarían la población por lo que en
su opinión la población seguiría
aumentando simplemente seguiría
aumentando hasta que ya no pudiera
sostenerse hasta que la productividad
real de la tierra no pudiera producir
suficientes calorías para alimentar a
todas esas personas él pensaba que
habría un límite superior natural con
base en la cantidad real de alimentos
que la tierra puede generar entonces
digamos que permítanme usar un color
diferente que él pensaba que había un
límite superior y una vez que se llegara
a ese límite superior de repente los
vicios de la humanidad surgirían y si
éstos no comenzaran a matar personas
entonces todas estas otras cosas lo
harían
las pestes plagas y luego hambrunas la
gente moriría de hambre de acuerdo con
él una vez que llegamos a este nivel
tal vez tuvimos un par de buenas
cosechas la gente se siente bien consigo
misma aumenta la población pero luego de
repente tenemos una mala cosecha o
debido a que hubo una mala cosecha la
gente comienza a pelear por los recursos
y comienzan las guerras o tal vez la
población es tan densa que se desarrolla
una plaga y luego tenemos una ola masiva
de muerte en la población y entonces
simplemente oscilar y amos alrededor de
este límite y algunas personas se
refieren a este límite como el límite
maltusiano pero es realmente el límite
en el que la población puede sostenerse
y desde el punto de vista de thomas
malthus reconoció que había mejoras
tecnológicas especialmente en cosas como
la agricultura y esta línea se estaba
moviendo hacia arriba a él le tocó ver
que esta línea subiera pero desde su
punto de vista sin importar cuán lejos
movamos esta línea la población siempre
la compensará y la alcanzará y
finalmente llegará
este límite maltusiano y entonces esas
mismas cosas no tan positivas de las que
habla sucederían realmente y algunas
personas ahora dicen o thomas malthus él
era tan pesimista obviamente estaba
equivocado mira lo que pasó tenemos
mucha comida en el planeta en este
momento hemos pasado por múltiples
revoluciones agrícolas y tienen razón en
los últimos 200 años desde malthus desde
principios de 1800 realmente hemos
podido aventajar al crecimiento de la
población entonces esta línea de aquí se
ha movido hacia arriba mucho más rápido
incluso que la población así que en este
momento en realidad tenemos más calorías
por persona en el planeta de las que
hemos tenido en cualquier momento de la
historia pero no estamos diciendo que
thomas malthus estaba equivocado sólo
estamos diciendo que tal vez sólo era un
poco pesimista acerca de cuándo se
alcanzaría ese límite ahora el otro
aspecto en el que se podría decir que
tal vez estaba equivocado fue este
principio de que una población
aumentaría si puede aumentar si hay
comida y si hay
la gente se reproduciría y un buen
contrapunto a eso es lo que hemos
observado ahora en las naciones modernas
y desarrolladas y esto justo aquí
muestra el crecimiento de la población
obtuve esto del banco mundial y muestra
el crecimiento demográfico de algunas
naciones modernas y desarrolladas
podemos ver que eeuu está bastante bajo
pero sigue siendo positivo todavía está
arriba del 0.5 por ciento pero incluso
eso suma cuando se contabilizan pero si
vemos aquí japón y alemania ambos tienen
menos inmigración que los eeuu
especialmente japón en realidad son
negativos entonces esta población
encerrada especialmente si tenemos en
cuenta que las personas no cruzan las
fronteras sólo la población en sí misma
crece en realidad tienen un crecimiento
negativo entonces hay alguna razón para
creer que esto es una prueba de que
thomas malthus estaba equivocado o no
del todo correcto no tuvo en cuenta que
tal vez cuando una sociedad se vuelve lo
suficientemente rica y educada puede no
poblar el mundo o tener tantos hijos
como se quiera
lo que pueden intentar hacer otras cosas
con el tiempo cualquier otra cosa así
que sólo quería exponerlos a esta idea
el tiempo dirá si thomas malthus tenía
razón o si podemos mantener siempre esta
línea de productividad alimentaria
creciendo más rápido que la población el
tiempo dirá si nuestras poblaciones
pueden llegar a hacer creo que podríamos
decir lo suficientemente desarrolladas
para que no crezcan exponencialmente tal
vez se conviertan en una población como
la de japón o alemania y la población
mundial especialmente si tenemos una
alta tasa de alfabetización finalmente
se estabilice y nunca tenga la
posibilidad de alcanzar ese límite
maltusiano pero pensé en presentarles
esta idea y ahora podrán ir a fiestas y
hablar sobre cosas como los límites
maltusiano y si quieren saber qué país
está más cerca del límite maltusiano en
este momento ya lo hemos hablado antes
un buen ejemplo de este caso es
bangladesh en este momento es el país
con mayor densidad de población del
mundo tiene 900 personas por kilómetro
cuadrado y solo para que se den una idea
eso es 30 veces más denso que
dos unidos entonces si tomáramos a cada
persona en los estados unidos y la
convirtieran en 30 personas en los eeuu
eso les daría una idea de cuán denso es
bangladesh y probablemente se deba en
cierta medida a que es una tierra muy
fértil el delta del río ganges
constituye esencialmente todo el país
pero ellos han tenido hambrunas en el
pasado lo han superado un poco pero
siguen teniendo grandes problemas con
las inundaciones y los recursos
esperemos que puedan mantenerse por
arriba de la curva